sometimes recruiters have a desire to
become a billing manager which is the
worst job in recruitment hands down and
they don't realize it and so as a
billing manager you've got to manage the
team you get paid on the team's
performance you get very little for the
team's performance your Billings drop
you get paid on your own Billings and
it's just like this really bad like
combination of structure for a billing
manager that I find doesn't doesn't work
well and I don't know why if I'm
thinking of this wrong or I'm the only
guy that's working this out but being a
billing manager uh it sucks but some
people need to become a billing manager
to realize it sucks and then go I would
much prefer to be an individual
contributor focus on my own desk bring
in the money for myself earn lots of
money and you know that's what I get a
lot of value out of so